all right then
um so
this evening i wish to do another book
recommendation video uh to show you some
of the books within my library
and we're gonna make this as brief as
possible and i have brought along my my
librarian cup
librarians the original search engine
so i'm going to be um
recommending some books that i think
will be beneficial for you
uh intellectually
as well as religiously
so i have some religious books set on
the side
and some books on history as well as
philosophy so
can everyone hear me pretty well is it
okay
how's the sound i just want to make sure
that everything's fine
um i also do apologize i look rather
fatigued it's because i am i don't get
much sleep these days
um and also a quick update for some of
you i will be attending another
uh hamza's den on friday inshallah
so i'll be doing an update on that very
soon as well
um so let's begin shall we because i
think that uh i get into this right
so let's start with philosophy yeah
philosophy
okay so one of the first books that i
really want to recommend is by william
barrett it's called irrational man
and this book
uh was really good uh in the sense that
when i first read this in undergraduate
years
um it really got me interested in
learning the other side of philosophy uh
what i call what we call existentialism
okay so a lot of people have very
negative perception of existentialism
however the existentialism that muslims
are usually exposed to
is typically of an atheistic variety and
this book is very fascinating in that
it's written so well
that um it's basically a primer on
existentialism and it discusses both the
atheistic and theistic
side of the philosophy so it goes into
kierkegaard quite
quite a bit
um so it showcases all of the elements
of existentialism existential is really
about it's not so much about like proofs
and logic and things like that it's more
about like trying to understand man's
experience with himself
okay so i generally perceive
uh purpose of their existence et cetera
et cetera so it's very fascinating from
that sense and i think it's good if you
want to understand existentialism a
little bit better so you can have a more
informed opinion about the subject and i
think this is the best primer on
the subject of existentialism okay
so i'm gonna put this one away i think
we're done with that one
all right then another one that i think
is really good now many of you have seen
me recommend this in the past
um
did i recommend this in the first video
i don't think i did did i
i don't think so but anyways pragmatism
a new name for some old ways of thinking
by william james
um this is the first real introduction
to pragmatism from the
anglo-american
perspective although he would argue that
pragmaticism is
and even goes in explaining how
pragmatism is also
helpful for the religious individual and
that explains things better than most
analytical philosophies and continental
philosophies and it discusses basically
just the basic ideas behind pragmatism
so if you want to understand where i'm
coming from when i say like i'm a
pragmatist philosopher this is a good
way to
to
to introduce yourself to
the philosophy of pragmatism
okay
let's continue
oh some of you were mentioning this in
the last stream and i thought i'd pull
it out just to impress you right so i
have here by allama dr mohammad iqbal
the reconstruction of religious thought
in islam i read this a long time ago i
still have it it's very old book
actually as you can tell
and um yeah it's very fascinating i
don't agree with all of his ideas but i
really admire his his coherence and his
level of thinking
he studied philosophy in in the uk i
believe was it yes in the united kingdom
and uh he's more of a kantian if
anything
he tries to involve kanteen philosophy
into islam and tries to explain islam
through continuism
um
so i don't agree with a lot of it but i
do think it's a very fascinating read i
think it's actually quite
well translated as well and i think that
it'd be interesting just for you to read
it um you don't have to agree with it
obviously but i think that
um i think it'll open your mind at least
towards understanding uh his thinking as
well as some uh muslims perspectives
towards philosophy and how we can use
philosophy to sort of better our
tradition sort of understand our
tradition
uh at least a speculative portions of
that right
so
um
like i said i do recommend reading it
just to sort of get yourself become
aware of his thinking and where he was
coming from during that period of time
and why a lot of people admire him for
his thinking so
that uh that's one and finally for
philosophy i'd like to discuss
this book by akbar ahmed it's
post-modernism and islam predicaments
and promises and it discusses the
contemporary
condition of the world
how post-modernism affects the muslim
mind as well as well primarily the media
in fact i actually quoted this book in
my lecture series on information
literacy i do highly recommend it it's
actually kind of hard to find
i think you can find the pdf very easily
but if you want to get a physical copy i
recommend it as well um
it's well written uh there are a lot of
things in here that i agree with
especially with his his examination of
western media
and western culture and how it affects
muslims but he's also very balanced he
doesn't just attack the western he
actually attacks
muslim societies as well for sort of
succumbing to
liberal mentalities but also sort of
abandoning our own tradition and this is
also the reason he sort of says well
this is the reason really why that
western uh society western culture is
controlling muslims is not because
really of western societies
you know own power but also but because
muslims themselves have sort of
succumbed to it by our own volition
right so i think this is a really good
book if you want a very um
comprehensive look
at
contemporary issues so
especially with respect to the media
all right then oops almost dropped some
books here okay so let's keep moving
along here all right a lot of stuff on
my desk let's go into history i think
history is nice i like history right
so uh this is also a book that i
recommended on my archive excuse me on
my information literacy uh course
um so here is a book by rosie bashir
called archive wars and this is actually
a really fascinating book
um
and it's the politics of history in
saudi arabia and she really discusses
uh how
saudi arabia at least the current
regime
controls its own history and its own
narrative by essentially deleting
archives and also historical sites and
only preserving some portions of those
things in order to teach its own version
of history
and uh she uses this as a primary
example because a lot of societies in
the past have done this as well by
deleting history by by by sort of
developing their own societies on the
basis of their own narratives of the
past by deleting
what actually happened
or preserving only certain portions of
it so this is a really fascinating it's
very thick actually very big book it's
really well written
i highly recommend it if you're if
you're interested in understanding how
saudi arabia the current political
regime operates excuse me
and also
why
uh this sort of
what is it retelling of history is very
dangerous because it controls
contemporary politics so whoever
controls history can actually control
current society and that's what she's
trying to teach so
very fascinating book okay oops put it
over here
all right so i also recommend this one
in my
information literacy course
and i'm not going to say the name out
loud but you can read it yourself and i
do apologize for the title but it's not
my fault
and unfortunately like i said a lot of
muslims don't write about these things
so non-muslims write about them so they
get to choose what they want to write so
anyways this is about new york times
bestsellers to be the bad blank
librarians of timbuktu for those of you
who've watched my lectures uh on this
book you already know the value of it
but essentially for those who haven't it
teaches about uh the heroics of
the clutter hedara
with respect to what happened in
timbuktu a couple of years back where al
qaeda
invaded timbuktu essentially occupied it
and was trying to burn down
manuscripts and other government things
and these librarians actually saved a
lot of ancient manuscripts and books
and it really explains the value of
their contribution and also the value of
these manuscripts and what they did and
gives you a more
a newfound appreciation for what
librarians do uh and uh yeah i think
it's a really good book to read it reads
like a fiction novel but it's actually
just really good in general
okay so i'm gonna put this one away um
did you do
what else
oh this one's a lovely book finally last
one in history
i like this one a lot a lot of people
haven't mentioned this book um
but and i don't know why because it's
really good uh so the enlightenment
quran
sorry
excuse me
the politics of translation and
construction of islam now what this book
is about don't be mistaken by the title
is that it discusses how the quran was
used by enlightenment philosophers
during the period of enlightenment
enlightenment thinkers in general and
what he goes to show and hear what he
proves in here is that
the
even though there's a myth that religion
that the enlightenment period was
against religion that wasn't actually
the case the enlightenment period was
against established christianity
political christianity right
institutionalized christianity
and in fact many enlightened thinkers
actually
complemented and promoted islamic ideas
by utilizing islamic references against
the church believe it or not even
atheists were actually more fond of
islam than they were of christianity in
many respects so he actually quotes a
number of sources from a lot of
enlightenment thinkers who actually
quoted the quran in order to refute
christians and the christian
establishment at the time
okay so yeah this is an interesting read
and i truly recommend it because it kind
of destroys this myth that religion was
you know
that people were against religion during
the enlightenment when really reality
was is that they weren't they were just
against christianity but they actually
used islam a lot in order to rebuke
christians so it's that's actually quite
fascinating so i think you should
definitely pick this up especially you
want to look into the history of the
enlightenment with respect to islam okay
so yeah
okay so that's good so i think we went
through history and
philosophy
um
let's look at
uh religion okay
i didn't have any fiction books today
maybe next time i'll do fiction
um
so this one is also recommended in my
information literacy course and uh it's
called the enlightenment from the sacred
precinct and it's one of the classical
works on information literacy from the
islamic perspective believe it or not
and uh this is a little short book but
it actually discusses how to properly
research and read
as a muslim
this is not like a polemic or anything
it actually discusses
using like and this is an actual
treatise by a classical scholar
and it's called the enlightenment from
the second precinct a manual on the arch
of reading okay this is a very
interesting read i'd recommend buying
this
um and yeah it's very fascinating how he
goes through he discusses like how to
read properly how to define words
properly how to understand words
properly um how to research things
properly how to look for proofs you know
etc etc it's very good
and it discusses how to be a good
student etc so
yeah recommend it a lot i do believe
it's in arabic but this is the
translated work okay
obviously scenario it was written
originally in arabic
actually yes yeah there it is the
original arabic text is actually in the
book as well so i do apologize i forgot
about that so yes the original arabic
text is also in the book
as well
okay so please recommended reading
get this we're going to be discussing it
more in information literacy as well so
all right then
last but not least
a book
that i truly recommend for everyone it's
very expensive though if you can get in
pdf get it in pdf but i mean just having
it is also nice as well
the compendium of knowledge and wisdom
by ibn rajas
this is
a commentary
on imam nawabi's
hadith collection
um
correct yes it is
uh
this is a a lovely book
um
it's just it's extremely comprehensive
that's all i have to say and it's one of
the only translated works on the subject
matter
and um yeah um
yeah basically
the 40 hadith yeah sorry
uh
so
like i said i'm very tired so i
apologize if i don't get all the details
right here
so but i use this every day actually i
look through it every single day to find
nuggets of wisdom it's really wonderful
um has so many references it's very
academic work i mean it's extremely well
written and translated excuse me and
it's just it's amazing to read i mean
there's just so much stuff in here that
you can
take out of it i mean it's it's
indispensable resource if i were to
recommend any book for ramadan
for you to read through aside from the
quran it would be this
it would be this book just reading
through the commentaries
of these hadith um
yeah and it's just it's just it's just
it's just i can't believe how much
information is in here i'm just i'm so
impressed that the authors were able
that the the translators were able to do
this and even provide all the academic
references i mean this must have taken
a decade or so to do i mean it's just
insane
how how wonderful this translation is so
please because it is quite expensive
yes so um
if you find a pdf do so but i really i
honestly i would i would ask you to buy
it because this in your library is
awesome
this should be right next to
you know your hadith collections or in
the quran okay
um so definitely recommend i'm a maliki
by fick
but
i take inspiration and knowledge from
all major scholars
and uh i have to tell you this is
probably the best work the best
commentary on hadith that i've ever read
at least up until this point in my life
so
okay so that is it
um
let's see who is it
it's it's published by torath publishing
okay which is in london london yes
all right
okay so that was it for those who asked
about the previous book enlightenment
from the sacred precinct the manual in
the art of reading which is also where i
got the inspiration for the name of my
course on information literacy
uh you know how to read uh so this is
inspired by this book like i said we'll
get into that more later all right then
so those are my recommendations for
today
i have a lot more books to recommend in
the near future however i just want to
leave you with that because i have too
many books and next time i also include
some fiction works
that i think all of you would enjoy
and also i think reading a lot of
fiction helps to also increase our
vocabulary increase our way of
also it helps us to increase our ability
to write and to communicate the more
that we read especially fiction i think
because fiction is really more of uh
more about communication than other
works right
it really requires you to be able to
sell an image to people sell a story to
people so the author is required to
communicate
at a vastly superior level than most um
i think
and uh to use words in a way that uh
that is much more artful
so i think that when you read fiction it
actually helps you to think better it
helps you to read better it helps you to
understand things better
so that's what we're going to be doing
i'm going to be showing you more fiction
works in the future classical works not
like you know a lot of
uh not too much contemporary fiction but
a lot of classical works where people
are much better writers i think
personally
so that's it uh
so um
i think yeah that's it that's all i have
any questions
like
i have not finished abdul hakim's book
yet i will and after that i will give
you my thoughts and recommend it
inshallah
how do i make time to read well reading
is part of my busy schedule
so
so i think that's uh
that's it
so
i will uh let you all go thank you very
much for your time i hope this video was
beneficial for you
and inshallah i hope you pick up some of
these books i will try to leave links in
the description box where you can
purchase these works
and the names of these works okay
and that's it so thank you very much